okay the other thing I want to ask you
about this is a serious thing we're
having a good time on the show and it's
also lovely but should we get rid of
live calls forever and never take live
calls again and the reason I say that is
that recently the feedback from the
audience from one part of the audience
has been brutal about taking live calls
and I like hearing from the audience in
a way that you can't really do with
voicemail I can't actually have a
conversation when we just play a
voicemail at the end of the show on
social media you can have it back and
forth but it's by text you can't
necessarily take the pulse of people in
the audience so I like live calls
because of the sort of communication
style that they present but there has
been some truly atrocious feedback from
a contingent of the audience and I know
it's important to remember that most
people we just don't hear from so the
people that are writing in that are
saying David kill live calls because
it's killing the show they it's a
self-selected group that is so furious
about the live calls that they're
choosing to write in individually the
calls do pretty well on YouTube and on
our platforms but there are lots of
general complaints about them and the
most common complaints are the people
are bringing up issues that aren't
interesting or they're bringing them up
in a way that is really annoying to
listen to or they have like a horrible
connection they're on speakerphone they
can't seem to spit out the question
whatever and the suggestion has been
made for us to screen calls in other
words for Pat or max to like talk to the
caller and do some kind of vetting and
then put them back into our hold queue
so that I can pick up without going into
details the phone system we have in the
workflow we have it just wouldn't allow
for that right now so our current setup
does not allow for that so the way it
works is I just see an area code and I
pick up on it and I'm hearing from the
caller for the first time at the same
time that the audience is that's the
system that we have and that's the
system we would have to use I'm not
ending live calls right now we are still
doing live calls on tomorrow's program
the Friday show as we normally do but I
do want to hear from the audience more
broadly and the reason I'm mentioning it
is when I don't ask for feedback the
feedback is subject to self selection
bias and people that really want to end
five calls are the only ones who email
so I would love to hear from people no
matter what your opinion is about live
calls so that hopefully we can make some
kind of decision about it
I like it some weeks it's great and some
weeks it's not so great
I feel like less than half the time
we'll get a quality call the thing is
though when we do get a quality call
it's a gem either it includes an awesome
debate between you and the caller or
it's just funny in some way and that's
why I don't want to see the segment go
personally much like grabbing your phone
and scrolling through social media the
reason that that can be so addictive is
that it is a variably timed reward thing
you might get on Facebook and have ten
great notifications or you might not and
that's what keeps you checking it
because those notifications release
dopamine and you get more and more
addicted to sorry I went into Alex Jones
mode anyway you get what you get
addicted to it it's a similar dynamic
with live calls where when we take a
call it could be another five hundred
thousand views on YouTube clip like that
time when three days after the election
some apology had called anything he
voted for Trump and within three minutes
he had realized that he made a major
major mistake I love that and they got
like half a million views on YouTube
or it's you know questions about what
what's my love life doing these days
which maybe is of interest to some
people but not to most in the audience
yeah and maybe the solution is to reduce
the number of live calls we used to do
just one segment of calls every week and
now we alternate so we'll either do one
or two to every other so we could bring
back the classic interviews every single
week but we got to hear from the audit
that's a possibility yes so let me know
we're not thinking about doing more life
calls okay so if you're worried that
we're gonna do more live calls
let me stem the tide of concern because
we are not doing more but what we want
to figure out is whether we should cut
it out altogether